mike miner who is coming hop perhaps his
best start of the season robbie grossman
will lead off
fastball strikes him out
and a good start for mike miner and the
royals
first and third cabrera
make it three as he finds the right
center field gap
taylor cuts it off scope scores
candelario all the way to third and
miguel cabrera delivers an rbi single
here in the first to get the tigers on
the board the good swings consistent
good swings four hits now in the six
advanced in the two games now it's eric
haas
one one pitch hot ground ball third got
it second base one first base got him
both
boy the royals and mike miner needed
that 24 year old native of springville
alabama casey mize first batter to face
in his whit mary field
[Music]
certainly the pitcher casing guys two
o'clock gets with very few top out
kansas city has runners at the corners
but only one away
ground ball softly to short charging
good one flips it down to castro one
really first
tigers turn the double play beautifully
turned by good run and castro
castro with a strong throw to first to
get solaire by inches 6-4-3
inning ending double play
jake rogers leading things off the
catcher for the tigers here fizz in the
third another 3-2 and a swing and a miss
and a high fastball struck him out
fastball they've been using on rogers
here got him out jonathan scobe singled
and he scored the game a long run
drives one to deep right field
back it goes solaire will watch it fly
away a two-run bomb
from jonathan scope and the tigers lead
it three-nothing
big blast
his 11th of the season remember how long
mike miner held that ball and maybe just
made him rush a little bit took his
concentration off a little higher than
he wanted it
because the scope makes him pay now the
switch hitting jamer candelario
gutierrez makes a sliding play pops up
to his feet and gets it to dozier
and candelario is out number two that's
a slick play right there
had top spin on it second hop was a
short hop people are gloving and guide
it over and the royals have two on with
one out carlo santana the 1-0
in the dirt gets away and the ball
escapes down to third goes lopez to
second base merrifield a golden
opportunity
to do some damage on casey mize it's a
wild pitch the pitch they give him the
green light he pulls it to the right
side
he will be thrown out but scoring from
third is lopez and moving two-third
is merrifield it's three to one the
royals cut the tigers lead to two load
the bases for kelvin gutierrez
way outside
wind comes down from third it's 3-2
and that's the second wild pitch in the
inning for casey mice he's over throwing
a little bit here mike miner goes back
to work here's eric haas
the ball struck pretty well to the left
side racing over his dice in the left
fielder and he climbs the wall did he
make the catch
he did what a play by gerard dyson
and miner on the mound just
applauding
the daring dive and climb up the wall by
gerard dyson that was an outstanding
play he peeked out at the wall and then
climbed it
using his right foot as leverage to gain
momentum up
and make an excellent play and
it's a big league change up two down in
the fourth inning
miner strikes out as four exactly where
he wants to put this pitch down right
there he head to ending number five
here's jake rogers
dozier is out
mirrorfield's out and dozier makes an
over-the-head catch two-way tester for
dozier fine athlete look at him he's
getting on the grass takes a step back
keep your eye on it good concentration
top of the order and robbie grossman
there's a wave and a miss and robbie
grossman down on strikes a one two three
inning for mike miner we're in the fifth
casey meisner's got the nine one and two
hitters to face oh line right off the
middle grab by casey mize that's amazing
finishing his motion falling off the
first base side line drive up the middle
and casey mize caught it
2-2 on the ground could be two
candelario's gonna have to turn it and
he does second double play turn behind
mice
[Music]
drives one to right field that's gonna
find the alley
solaire will watch it skip off the wall
and miguel cabrera trots in with a two
out double
that slider down and then
continues to wear out right center field
scoring position for eric haas who
delivers
a bullet to left hit sharply cabrera is
going to have to hold it third is it
first in third tigers trying to add to a
3-2 lead two good swings going to bring
on a fresh arm and right-hander kyle
zimmer to face the right-handed swinging
dazz camera
through the ground ball shot up the
middle into center field a base hit
cabrera in the score stopping at second
haas big two out
rbi single for daz cameron the tigers
take a 4-2 lead in the sixth good short
compact swing hit it right back where it
came from two-run lead
he got him looking
kept testing that outside corner and
finally got the call to away
and he got him looking he freezes
solaire dice in the batter gerard is
grounded out flying out
[Music]
dyson strokes one into the right field
corner
we'll see how far he can go as grossman
plays it off the wall and dyson
is going to hold with a one-out double
we're going to recognize that pitch
fastball right there and he's able to
get ahead of it dice into third with two
out that'll bring up nikki lopez here's
the pitch a swing a flare towards left
that's a base hit dyson will score the
royals are within one
and he's done it all year with two outs
he gets on base and gets the game to win
barefield out comes the skipper aj hinch
he will make a pitching move here mize
is out looks like peralta is coming in
the right he sets
3-2 swinging a miss he got him on
strikes with a fastball down in the
strike zone the bottom of the ninth
could the royals have it in them tonight
they're gonna see some heat here from
lefty gregory soto
[Applause]
final hitter final out another 2-2 he
got him soto wins the battle tigers win
the game and the series